[Music]
today I want to show you the future of
checkout forms in progressive web apps
using that browser payments API instead
of giving users a long tedious checkout
form that they're likely not to finish
we give them a simple Buy Now button
that uses a credit card saved on their
browser so it behaves a lot more like
in-app payments do on native mobile
devices this is very recent technology
and it's only available in Chrome and
Microsoft edge to facilitate this
feature in angular we'll be using
stripe elements which has the added
benefit of supporting Apple pay on
safari browsers if you're new to the
channel make sure to subscribe and if
you're serious about payments check out
my full stack stripe payments course
which you can find on angular firebase
comm and is free to all pro members to
build this payment request button the
first thing I'm going to do is start
with a fresh angular 5 app at this point
you'll also need a stripe account and
you'll want to reference the payment
request button in the stripe
documentation what we're building is
just a simple component that has a
random product I found on Amazon and
then when the Buy Now button is clicked
it will bring up the browser payments
API when the user clicks pay it's going
to send the payment information off to
stripe and stripe will respond with that
payment source you can see we have a
source ID here in the console as well as
information about the users credit card
but no information that would actually
be a client-side security risk now
jumping into our angular code the first
thing we'll have to do is add the stripe
j/s version 3 tag to index.html stripe
j/s has its own stripe class so we need
to register it with typescript and
typings DTS from there we need to
instantiate stripe somewhere in our
project to do that I'm going to use an
angular service which I'm calling the
payment service after we generate it
with the CLI we can go in there and
instantiate it with our stripe
publishable key for the sake of
simplicity I'm using the key directly in
the angular service but a better
approach would be to manage your keys in
your angular environment that way you
can use your test key in your
development app and your live key in
your actual deployed production app now
we can build the actual component that's
going to do all the work I'm calling it
the payment request component
because we're using stripe elements in
this component we need to wait for the
view to initialize before we can
actually attach the payment button to do
that we use the after view init
lifecycle hook and angular we're also
going to bring in our payment service
and then we'll initialize a couple of
input variables first the amount will be
the amount of the payment that we're
making and the label is whatever we're
paying for the input properties allow
you to use this as a child component for
example if you had a shopping cart you
could easily pass the total amount and
label of that car down to the child
component from there we're going to set
a few variables for the information that
we get back from stripe elements
including the elements object itself the
payment request and the payment request
button we'll see these in action in just
a minute here then to actually mount the
element in the Dom we use the view child
decorator quickly I'll jump over the
HTML to show you how that looks
view child is pointing to a template
reference variable called pay element so
all we do is set up an empty div here
and then do you hatch pay element this
div is going to be replaced by the
actual stripe elements button switching
back over to the typescript will first
inject the payment service in the
constructor now we have about five
different steps we need to go through
which I'll explain to you one by one the
first step is to instantiate the payment
request object that object has a number
of different parameters that you can
pass to it but the two we're going to
pass to it for right now are just the
amount and the label we can access
stripe from our payment service and then
call a payment request and we'll set the
country the currency as well as the
total amount and the label again the
amount and the label correspond to our
input properties step two is to
instantiate the stripe elements object
elements contain the actual UI
components that we get from stripe Jas
that's just an easy one line statement
then we can move on to step 3 where we
actually register an event listener for
when the user submits their source to
stripe and stripe responds back with the
actual card details when stripe responds
with the card details that's the point
when you would send a request to your
back-end to actually charge the card or
just save the card on a customer account
that's a whole nother challenge to
overcome so for right now I'm just going
to console.log the
and then I'm going to set a timeout to
simulate the call to the back end
normally you would use the angular HTTP
client to make a call to your back-end
but for right now I'm just going to
pretend that I received a successful
response and then call event complete
success you could also call event fail
here or a number of other validation
errors provided by stripe the next thing
we do is create the actual instance of
the UI button from stripe elements so we
say elements create payment request
button then we tell it to reference the
payment request object that we've
already created this part is optional
but you can also control the style and
the theme of the button just past a
style object and then set the
corresponding options that you want that
takes care of step four now the final
step is to mount the actual payment
button in the Dom to do this I'm going
to use an async function you could
technically use rxjs here but I don't
think there's really any advantage to
doing so the purpose of this function is
to see if the browser supports the
payments API to do that we say payment
request can make payment which is going
to return a promise if we get a positive
result then we can go ahead and mount
our payment request button to the native
element that we retrieved from view
child otherwise the result is going to
be null so we can just console.log a
helpful error message now let's go into
Chrome and test it out we should be good
to go right well not exactly
it looks like our button is not showing
up here and we're getting an error
message from stripe saying that we need
to be serving over HTTPS the problem
here is that the browser payments API
only works when you serve with an SSL
certificate and that goes for
development on localhost as well it is
possible to run NG serve with an SSL
certificate if you happen to have an SSL
certificate line around which not many
people do and a self-signed certificate
is not going to work either luckily
there's a pretty easy solution and
that's a service called end Rock or at
least I think that's how you pronounce
it it allows you to create an HTTP
tunnel that will allow you to serve your
app on localhost while also forwarding
it to a valid HTTPS connection that you
can use with the payment request API you
need to download the application on your
local machine which is going to vary by
operating system but the setup is really
easy overall once you have it set up
you can create a custom command in your
package.json file to run this command
quickly the actual command you use might
look a little bit different because you
have to point to the actual end grok
install on your local machine then you
call HTTP 4200 and I also had to set the
host header to 8080 for just some random
air that was coming out once you have
that done you'll first want to run ng
serve and then you'll open up a second
terminal tab and run the NPM run and
grot command that we just created that's
going to open up this window that's
going to take you to the other side of
the tunnel the one we're looking at is
the HTTP endpoint that is forwarding
from localhost 4200 you can go ahead and
copy and paste that into a browser and
then it should magically bring up the
payment button that we had created
before the forwarding process is really
slow but it does give you a reliable way
to test the payment request button like
I said at the beginning I believe this
is going to be the future of payments in
the browser it makes life so much easier
for both the developer and the customer
and things like that tend to be adopted
pretty quickly if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you're
serious about payments consider becoming
a pro member at angular firebase com
you'll get access to the stripe payments
project which is designed for developers
who are building stripe features into
real world applications
thanks for watching and I'll see you
soon
[Music]
you